Whenever unemployment comes down - even if
only very slightly - it sounds like really
good news. It's great that productive forces
in the economy are growing and there’ll
be a little more money in people's pockets
soon
But if one gets more ambitious about human
potential, the picture gets more complicated
and darker than what governments make out.
Unemployment means being, generically, out
of work.
But let’s coin a new word:
MISEMPLOYMENT
It means being in work but of a kind that
fails to tackle with any real sincerity the
true needs of other people: merely exciting
them to unsatisfactory desires and pleasures
instead; the way Primark, Patek Philippe and
youporn.com might.
This man is misemployed:
Similarly, a man employed by the Sands Casino
in Las Vegas to hand out flyers to tourists
in order to entice them to use slot machines
is clearly 'employed' in the technical sense.
He's marked as being off the unemployment
registers. He is receiving a wage in return
for helping to solve some (small) puzzle of
the human condition of interest to his employers:
that not enough tourists might otherwise leave
the blue skies and heat of main street to
enter the air-conditioned halls of an Egyptian-themed
casino.
The man is indeed employed, but he’s also
in truth dramatically misemployed.
His labour is generating capital, but it is
making no contribution to human welfare and
flourishing. He is joined in the misemployment
ranks by people who make cigarettes, addictive
but sterile television shows, badly designed
condos, ill-fitting and shoddy clothes, deceptive
advertisements, artery-clogging biscuits and
highly-sugared drinks.
The rate of misemployment in modern economies
is very high.
While we may be genuinely grateful for any
job we’re given, at the back of our minds
we all - as employees - hope for something
else:
that our work can contribute in some real
way to the common good; that we can make a
modest difference.
Governments have, with some success, been
learning techniques to reduce the overall
rate of unemployment. In the language of the
field, they do this by 'stimulating demand.'
Though technically effective, this method
fails to draw any distinction between good
and bad demand and therefore between employment
and misemployment.
The real trick to bringing down the rate of
misemployment isn't just to stimulate demand
per se, it’s to stimulate the right sort
of demand: to excite people to buy the ingredients
of true satisfaction, to want the things that
really matter, and therefore to give individuals
and businesses a chance to direct their labour,
and make profits, in meaningful areas of the
economy.
Employment figures aren’t irrelevant - they
matter a great deal. They are the first things
to be attended to. But these raw figures mask
a more ambitious index we should get around
to building in the future: one that measures
misemployment and hence shows how intelligently
and responsibly we are deploying human capital,
that is, using up people’s lives.